hi I'm Christopher hin and today we're
going to be talking about Koshi nag so
Koshi nag means hip throw pretty direct
translation um my koshin isn't
dramatically different than anyone
else's kosin I think it's pretty pretty
run-of-the-mill I don't have a lot of
great insights to koshin it kind of just
is what it is I'm going to share a
couple little things that I think maybe
I look at a little differently than
other people but really no big
difference mostly what this video is
going to be is I'm going to show you how
I get my students into koshin and I feel
like I have a lot of success with this
when I was learning koshin I felt like
it was something that for beginners was
really difficult to learn and and you
know the students who kind of had
experience with other things were able
to get koshinaga pretty quickly but
students who had had no experience with
that really seem to have a difficulty
learning kosagi so over the years I
built a very specific way to get
students into koshin and I'm going to
share that with you today so if you have
trouble with koshin this video will
probably be a good one for you and
particularly if you have students that
you're having a really hard time
explaining to them how to get into
koshin I think the way that I get
through it is really straightforward and
will kind of help so I'm going to get
Josh out here and we're going to go to
work Josh
[Music]
[Applause]
all right let's talk about
Koshi so koshin nag means a hip toss in
iido or hip projection um in iido it's
the throw that I think looks the most
like a judo throw and so I think it's
one of the throws that most of the
people who are serious about being
Marshall really feel like um is a good
throw in
Aikido there is a lot of function in
understanding this throw but the time it
takes generally to set it up isn't
useful for us and so most of the time
when we're we're doing koshin they
should kind of just be set up on the fly
so it really doesn't work as well as
judo throws for clinch grappling as judo
throws do so um if you're going to
clinch grapple there's not a way around
it you can't really master koshin and
then you know as much as a judo guy you
still got to do Judo right so um it's
not a lot of what people think it is and
in fact I think a lot of the time what's
kind of happening in kosin is like you
know let's just go from showman just
it's really show like so if I come in
and this guy's coming towards me here
that
I'm okay so so we just learned that uh
you you can't do koshinaga very easily
with the mic pack on so I'm going to be
gingerly when I do it this time so uh
when uh this guy's coming in a lot of
times what's happening is I'm just kind
of bumping him off a little bit and it's
not this big dramatic throw it's like he
just kind of hits the the the edge of my
hips and the reason that happens is
because you know so kosin most of the
time and you see it mostly in the fors
like this it's coming because we have a
wide situation there's a few exceptions
like a riot or there's a couple
exceptions to this but generally have a
wide situation and so what's happening
for the koshinaga is as he's pushing
into that I'm coming down low boom and
catching him right here and then in that
catching um I can kind of just shove him
off a little bit right which gives me
the ability to to escape out of there so
it kind of kind of gives me a little
oomph to get out of there and that's the
way I use it most of the time is just
kind of this really simple little pop in
fact when you see it done in our gazer
randori most of the time it really
doesn't look like anything other than a
little bump and the guy kind of stumbles
back and then the other guy can escape
so that's how we use it most of the time
um however I think the full function of
learning how it works is really good
it's really good for learning to take
body weight and it's really good for
learning to fall and to trust your fall
so a lot of really good stuff comes from
that all right so I'm going to show you
how I would teach a beginner to do this
so and I'll use Josh because uh I'm
going to mess up my mic pack if I if I
do this wrong so okay uh what I would
have the beginner do is just bend over
right in half so they make this L shape
like this okay first thing I would do is
explain to them that if uh you resist me
and I push High okay you feel that in
your low back and if I resist you and
you push high now you feel nothing right
okay so that's really easy for Josh he
can do that all day whereas if I push up
here and he resists that's some work for
him right so and and take that time to
explain that if they're sitting right
where your belt is on your hips then
actually let me put it this way so it's
easy to see I don't know maybe I can get
with the other cameras but if they're
right here where your hips are then you
you're going to have a lot more
stability uh whereas up here your low
back's going to take the work because of
the lever of the back and so I just
basically take some time and explain
that to them and tell them you know when
you're putting someone uh setting
someone up for koshinaga you don't want
them up here because it's hard on your
back you want to make sure that they're
down here so that's the first part of it
okay next part is I'd have them bend
over and I don't want them to bend their
knees or anything else and then I have
their partner just lay across okay and
then Josh is going to see if there's any
way he could pick me up or anything else
from this position right and he can't
nothing right my my feet are on the
ground okay now I will say when you're
doing this really make sure that the UK
so that's me in this case um resists the
urge to load themselves up where they
should be right so they shouldn't be
trying to do that they should just be
flat footed and they should lean forward
and see if they get up anywhere right
and and they won't okay now next next
thing you tell him is okay now this guy
so what Josh is going to do is he's
going to bend his knees so his hips are
a little lower than mine right so a
little lower and now I'm going to do the
same thing I'm just going to lean
forward and Josh going to see if he can
get me up at all H not really not really
too much right a little bit but not too
much okay so that's the next stage in
the progression and again from this
stage make sure that the this person
isn't really trying to jump up on there
and set themselves up all they're doing
is leaning forward and seeing where they
get okay now next stage is Josh is going
to lean his back towards me like this so
see how he's like arching his or arching
like til tilting his back towards me so
then from this tilting the back on
forwards I'm going to do exactly the
same thing I'm just going to lay forward
exactly like I did before and he's going
to twist a little bit and look all of a
sudden my hips come up really really
nice up off the ground okay and that's
because of this this progression of
ideas now when we teach it to our
students a lot of times we forget all
these little things that we know how to
do and so it's kind of hard you got to
kind of reverse engineer like well how
do I get that really nice throw to set
up like that so this is a way I think
it's really clear for students and when
you have them like well can you get
their feet up off the ground easily or
not get their feet up off the ground
easily and they kind of see this
progression and how you know like making
sure that their hips are lower that's
one thing they have to do making sure
they tilt their back towards the other
person that's one thing they have to do
and then rolling over and standing up as
one action that's another thing they
have to do and so I think that breaks it
down simple enough for beginners that
they can get it and I've had a lot of
lot of success with this meaning a lot
of times people come in off the street
and I get them doing koshin day one so
it's a good method in my experience to
use um as far as that goes really
there's not that much in-depth crazy
stuff about koshinaga it's a hip throt
toss um it looks really big and
demonstrations and pretty in my
experience practically it almost never
comes off like that now I have video I
think I put up not too long ago actually
of me doing it years ago I did a really
nice koshin on Michael Varon um that
that is not the kind you see in this um
so they do can totally happen in our
iido experience but um they're not they
don't work best for that right in my
opinion most of the time they're just
kind of this little boom and they kind
of fly off and and you get away which is
most of the time what we want them for
in Nido but I think they're a good
practice tool for all the reasons I said
and I think this is a good progression
to get through to that um so yeah I
don't have a lot of exciting stuff to
say about kosagi it's a good throw um
it's one of the basic throws um and now
we're into the the less controversial
throws so uh I'm Chris fry thanks for
watching this is Joshua tii and my
salana McDaniel is right there behind
that one we'll see you guys in the next
video
[Music]